طلب مركز السيطرة على الأمراض (cdc) مسؤولي الصحة العامة بالولاية
الاستعداد لتوزيع
لقاح في
وقت مبكر من نهاية الشهر المقبل ،
كما أرسل أيضًا وثائق تخطيط
تقدم تفاصيل حول التوزيع ومن
يجب تلقيحهم أولاً مع التركيز على
العاملين الأساسيين في الرعاية الصحية
ولفترة طويلة.  - بدأ المقيمون في مجال الرعاية
الصحية وموظفوها الآن كما تعلمون ، مؤخرًا العديد من
المرشحين للقاحات المرحلة
الثالثة من التجارب ، وفي الأسبوع الماضي قال الدكتور
أنتوني فوسي ورئيس إدارة الأغذية والعقاقير ستيفن
هان إن
مجموعات معينة قد تحصل على لقاح قبل
اكتمال تلك التجارب إذا كانت
البيانات إيجابية للغاية  الآن
لدى
ضيفتنا التالية شكوكها ساسكيا بوبيسكو هي عالمة أوبئة في
أستاذ جامعة جورج ميسون
بوبيسكو ، نحن نقدر وجودك معنا ،
ما رأيك في هذا التوجيه الجديد
والجدول الزمني الذي يشير
إليه أنه مقلق للغاية أعتقد أنه من
السابق لأوانه للغاية القلق هو ذلك
سنطرح اللقاحات للعاملين في
مجال الرعاية الصحية في
وقت مبكر جدًا في المرحلة 3
قبل أن نحصل على البيانات اللازمة لدعمها ،
فأنت تقول إنه من الصعب رؤية هذا على أنه
أي شيء آخر غير
دفعة لقاح ما قبل الانتخابات ، لذا فأنت
قلق من أن هذا سيتم تسييسه ، فماذا
تقصد
أنه من الصعب عدم قول ذلك إذا كانت
اللقاحات  من المفترض أن يتم
تأجيلها في الأول من تشرين الثاني (نوفمبر) والانتخابات في
3 تشرين الثاني (نوفمبر) حقًا ، إنه أمر مقلق للغاية
أننا فجأة ندفع من خلال العديد من
بروتوكولات الأمان للقاحات من أجل السلامة
والتي يمكن أن
يكون لها تداعيات خطيرة للغاية
وجهود للرئيس ترامب
لدفع هذا من خلال  مقال انتخابي
مثير للقلق للغاية من
وجهة نظر الصحة العامة من وجهة نظر السلامة
ولكن أيضًا من
وجهة نظر الثقة والعلم ، لذلك قال كل من
الدكتور أنتوني فوسي ومفوض إدارة الأغذية والعقاقير
ستيفن هان الموجود في
فرقة عمل فيروس كورونا
إن اللقاح قد يكون
متاحًا
تم الانتهاء من مجموعات معينة قبل التجارب السريرية
إذا كانت البيانات تشير بأغلبية ساحقة إلى
أنها آمنة وفعالة
فماذا عن ذلك إذا كان  تشير البيانات إلى
أن هذا آمن للغاية وفعال ،
فهل يستحق الأمر محاولة
إيصاله إلى
بعض الأشخاص في وقت مبكر ، وأعتقد أن
أكبر قطعة هي
أن الفكرة الفعالة والآمنة إلى حد كبير
، والحقيقة
هي أن العديد من هؤلاء لم يصلوا إلى
المرحلة الثالثة حتى أواخر شهر يوليو
يعني هذا أنه يتعين عليك تسجيل 30 ألف
شخص
في كثير من الحالات يجب أن يكون لديك لقاحان ،
فكيف يمكنك
بالفعل تسجيل هذا العدد الكبير من الأشخاص
وجمع البيانات الكافية في هذه المرحلة
لنشر ذلك بأمان لتقول إنه لا بأس
للعاملين في مجال الرعاية الصحية
لأن  الحقيقة هي أنك تعلم أننا لا
نريد دفع هذا الأمر ، ونحن
لسنا هناك حتى الآن الكثير من هذه المرحلة الثالثة
تستغرق سنوات في الإعداد ، وحتى لو كانت
لدينا تلك البيانات الجيدة للغاية
التي لا نملكها ببساطة  في الوقت الحالي ،
ستكون هذه
لعبة كرة مختلفة
تمامًا وبصراحة لا نرى ذلك من
وجهة نظر زمنية في عقلك ما يجب أن
يحدث قبل توزيع اللقاح ،
أعتقد بأي شكل من الأشكال ما إذا كان يجب أن يكون في خط المواجهة
عاملين أو منتشرين في جميع أنحاء البلاد ،
أعتقد أننا بحاجة إلى الحصول مرة أخرى كما
ذكر الدكتور فالشي بيانات إيجابية للغاية
ليس فقط أنها فعالة كما
تعلم أننا بحاجة للتأكد من أنها
تعمل 50 من الوقت الذي تعلم
فيه أنها تحمي بالفعل 50
من الذين تم تطعيمهم ولكن  أيضًا أننا
لا نواجه أي نتائج سلبية تتعلق بالسلامة
أو أحداث اللقاح السلبية
لأنه في الوقت الحالي في الولايات المتحدة لدينا
للأسف الكثير من التردد بشأن
اللقاح وآخر شيء نريد القيام به هو
دفع هذا لأسباب سياسية
وزيادة دفع هذا اللقاح  التردد
وعدم الثقة
في cdc أو العلم وراء ذلك